o boa tarde a todos
pra mim é uma satisfação imensa está com
vocês e podendo compartilhar um pouco da
minha história é o que vocês irão ver
isso nada mais é do que uma trajetória
de vida com muita dificuldade mas que
nós estamos aqui para dizer que todo
mundo é capaz são regiane silva nascida
em abaetetuba é não é o meu interior ele
fica no interior de abaetetuba é uma
cidade a 51 quilômetros aqui da capital
estão cursando o 6º período de
administração e como já foi dito foi
premiada no quadro jovens inventores do
caldeirão do huck
bom gente é eu sempre estudei em escola
pública e sempre tive muitas
dificuldades para conseguir chegar à
minha escola e eu mostrarei um vídeo pra
vocês onde vai dizer onde eu moro é a
distância que eu percorri a para chegar
às 7 horas na nome na escola e eu vejo
assim que muitas pessoas ela tem muitas
oportunidades mas muito não agarrou e eu
pra mim conseguir chegar à escola eu
tinha que enfrentar isso aqui
[Música]
na casa de regiane todo mundo acorda bem
cedo seu sabará como é conhecido o pai
da jovem sai para colocar na pista
enquanto isso dona regina preparar o
café e em seguida vai acordar os filhos
ainda são quatro horas da manhã ea
correria já é grande na casa da
ribeirinha é que o ônibus escolar sai
daqui a pouco às 6 horas irão seguir por
este estreito rio nesta pequena
embarcação conhecida como casco
depois de chegarem ao ponto a caminhada
agora é a fest por este ramal de terra
batida
o trajeto de dois quilômetros até o
ônibus
[Aplausos]
que horas da manhã o ônibus pára em
frente à escola cristo trabalhador onde
estuda regiane 11 45 da manhã é o
horário que regiane sai da escola refaz
todo o percurso mostrado agora há pouco
e só chega em casa por volta das 2 horas
da tarde e todos os dias
esse era minha trajetória para mim
chegar à escola todos os dias tinha um
momento que não dá vontade de desistir
porque eu pensava assim que nada
adiantar porque era muito comum na minha
comunidade nós terminar o ensino médio e
fica ali ter os seus filhos casinha de
madeira de palha e aí é ser a vida então
eu dizia assim que não adiantava a gente
passar todo esse sacrifício que vocês
estão vendo para depois morrer da beira
como dizer muitas dizem mas aí muel
sempre china uma comigo que aquilo que
me motivava todas as vezes era dar o
melhor para a minha família
te amo minha família da vida que a gente
tinha que não era fácil e todos os dias
eu ia mas quando eu pensava em desistir
à minha família ea minha motivação e aí
eu todos os dias ea colocar uma tap com
o meu pai e meu pai eu venho de uma
família de pescadores de matapi e aí
todos os dias eu ia com o meu pai
colocar os matapi e todos os dias o meu
pai ele reclamava que cada vez mais a
qualidade do camarão já estava
diminuindo e ele dizia que aquilo era um
problema porque daqui a um tempo não se
tinha mais camarão e eu ficava
preocupado com aquilo olhava aquela
situação porque era dali que nós tiramos
nosso sustento era dali que a gente ia
vender o camarão para poder comprar
outros alimentos mas só que eu vendo
aquela situação e um certo dia
chegou na minha casa uma pessoa a pessoa
é esta que me fez uma proposta falou
assim regiane tem vontade de ser uma
pesquisadora
eu não sabia não tinha idéia do que
seria eu aceitei porque ele disse que se
eu aceitasse a ganhar uma bolsa de
iniciação científica de r$100 e pra mim
aquilo era tudo eu pensei esse post é
uma bolsa de iniciação científica vou
poder ajudar minha família e então eu
peguei eu quero professor ele falou
assim então você tem uma semana pra você
detectar um problema e ter uma solução e
me dizer o que você quer fazer
e aí como vocês sabem que vida de
pesquisadora não é fácil
jamais é fácil então eu comecei a olhar
aquela situação ali é o meu redor e eu
dizer o que eu vou fazer mas só que eu
vivenciava o problema todos os dias que
olhava para o chill todas as vezes que
olhava pra minha comunidade que cada vez
mais aquilo que estava nos dando
sustento estava acabando
então o que eu fiz peguei liguei pro
professor falei assim o professor
gilberto
eu acho que eu já sei o que eu quero
fazer e ele falou assim eu contei o que
eu queria fazer o qual o problema que eu
tinha visto e ele falou assim é isso
mesmo regiane se é isso que você quer
então a gente vai fazer isso que você
está propondo
mas assim pra gente chegar aonde a gente
quer com uma proposta a gente precisa
ter alguém ao nosso lado que acredite na
gente e essa pessoa é o professor
gilberto silva que está ali na platéia
né
nos assistindo eu digo pra ele que ele é
um homem apaixonado pelo que faz
é um homem que ama o que faz e sempre
quando eu comecei a pesquisar a primeira
coisa não sabia nada de computador o
computador pra mim era minha calculadora
que usava para fazer cálculo na escola
então a primeira dificuldade de mim era
isso
como é que eu vou fazer relatório como é
que eu vou fazer é um novo mundo pra mim
eu vivia o meu mundo e ele disse 'não
regiane você vai você vai conseguir vou
te ajudar e assim nos fóruns
tinha vezes que eu chegava na minha casa
que eu não conseguia ele eu chegava
falar um monte de coisa para os meus
pais que o professor queria me até mesmo
eu falava se que ele brigava comigo e
que eu não queria mais fazer aquilo
aí a minha mãe ligava pra ele ele fazia
minha mãe diz acreditar no que eu falei
porque não aguentava não sabia mais o
que fazer porque era muito difícil mas
aí ele nunca desistiu de mim e aí veio a
idéia que é uma tap ecológico uma tapa e
ecológico
essa armadilha que vocês estão vendo
aqui está o convencional ele é um
espaçamento muito pequeno e ele é feito
com fibra todo o tecido com fiba e esse
matapi ele capítulos camarões
pequenininho e isso o ciclo de vida dos
camarões eleição afetado então foi isso
que eu tentei que tem olhado e por isso
que cada vez mais e acabando camarão
porque porque todo mundo pescava com
esse mata pe convencional e eu olhei
para aquele matapi eu falei assim o pai
a gente aumentar esse espaçamento aqui
será que ele não vai capturar somente
camarões graúdos
ele olhou assim pra mim ele disse
certamente esse regiane
mas nem vai me dar mais trabalho porque
eu não aguento mais
aí eu phishing então pronto o pai eu já
sei o que eu vou fazer
então a partir daí eu comecei a
pesquisar e todos os dias
meu projeto mata pe ecológico é uma
armadilha ecológica para capturar o
camarão
a idéia surgiu devido um problema que eu
identifiquei a pesca do camarão que é a
captura das câmaras pequenos há mais de
30 anos e eu peço que o tio é a
quantidade de camarão cada vez mais está
a diminuir os pescadores cada vez querem
pegar mais problema é que os pescadores
eles capturam os chamados pequenos de
forma inadequada e com isso vai o ciclo
de vida do camarão diminui em cima
tecnológica é feito com uma tala do gil
pat e também com cipó tirada natureza
tona com essa razão que é o babaçu eo
farelo onde nós vamos colocar aqui
dentro do matapi e vamos amarrar e
fechar quilos sendo que ele tem esse
espaçamento que é um pouquinho maior
onde os camarões vão entrar por essa
abertura
só que os pequenos eles vão conseguir
sair por esse espaçamento porque é bem
maior que vai capturar apenas os
camarões adultos de dificuldade dela foi
enfrentar o pai porque ela é total de
camarão guitarra adam e ele não queria
pensando que ela tá fazendo mal mas nada
está fazendo bem né
normalmente eu achava coisa estranha a
capital vai acabar o pequenino é meu
dinheiro estrangeiro é e siga aquilo lá
eu estava fazendo a coisa certa lá
embaixo
normalmente é uma coisa tap
[Música]
eu fui melhor da forma de bota porque
vai ter que partir de agora quem carol
a gente vai dar um jeito mas chamaram
presente a ideia que se todas acima tap
ecológico né em quatro a cinco meses
a gente já percebe uma diferença muito
grande no rio por conta que o ciclo de
vida camarão até a fase adulta é curta
juntamente com o professor gilberto
nos doamos desde ataques e ecológico
para algumas famílias e todos os dias
pela manhã nós vamos pesar e medir os
camarões que se capturá lo
[Música]
ou seja lupion
eu disse hoje o pai viu como só tá
pensando o camarão é o resto foi também
na qualidade de collor nunca mais quero
muito trabalhar a fazenda só se chamará
hoje a manter fábio lembrou na região
gostou da qualidade do camarão vezes
olha como a nossa filha agora foi igual
ao que se diz vale a pena ver
então pra mim chegar a esse resultado
para convencer o meu pai eu precisava de
10 mata piso ecológico tudo conforme o
que eu tinha adaptado e aí ele falou
assim que ele não ia gastar tempo comigo
porque era tempo perdido mas desde que
eu dessa minha bolsa durante dois meses
para ele tudo estaria resolvido
aí eu falei assim não tem outra escolha
eu preciso dar continuidade no meu
projeto pra ver se vai funcionar
aí o que eu fiz peguei dele eu sei
primeiro sem lei disse agora se ele de
conversa foi fechou aos 10 matapi aí
todos os dias eu ia colocar com a minha
mãe a minha mãe sempre estar do meu lado
mesmo sabendo que não ia dar certo quero
que ela dizia mas ela estava ali para me
apoiar
apenas o professor gilberto sempre
acreditou em mim não região vai lá que
vai dar certo a gente vai conseguir ter
um resultado bom
e aí quando a gente
quando nós
fomos pesar todos os dias nas pesavam
mais 'media os camarões do matapi como e
do matapi ecológico e quando foi a
última semana do mês
o que nós fizemos pegamos uma tap
ecológico e medimos o comprimento de uma
do camarão capturado naquele matapi e o
que nós constatamos foi que 77,1
centímetro que era o tamanho do camarão
que se pegava no camaro no map ecológico
ou seja era bem maior do que numa
terapia convencional se capturava -
porque os pequeninos saiu só ficava os
grandes só que no convencional pegava
mais e aí nós fomos pra feira eu com meu
pai certa porque todos os dias ele
prende à quadra no final da semana ele
ia para a cidade pra feira vendeu
camarão e quando chegamos lá eu levei o
meu pandeiro de camarão né
coloquei lá no ato que o punho todo
mundo conta o quilo do camarão quanto é
o quilo do camarão aí eu peguei e 88
reais o quilo
coloquei vendi meu camarão eo papai
ficou lá tentando vender óleo camarão
molho de camarão graúdo e o camarão já
estava quase estragando para ele
conseguir vender foi obrigado a lhe
vender quatro reais o quilo
aí no final que constatamos que pegamos
- a qualidade foi maior mas só que nós
tivemos o mesmo lucro e aí ele pegou
vendeu camarãozinho dele fizemos compra
e ele de cabeça baixa triste chegou em
minha casa olhou pra mim e disse à minha
filha de hoje em diante eu estou com
você e a partir de então vieram as
conquistas e aí nós começamos
é com esse projeto participar de várias
feiras tanto nacionais quanto
internacionais
o meu maior sonho gente pode parecer
bobagem mas era conhecer belém
meu sonho era conhecer a capital do meu
estado então quando eu comecei com este
projeto achei que não fosse sair do meu
interior
aí a minha primeira feira foi no hangar
e eu já ganhei o primeiro lugar e uma
credencial para a eslováquia
não sabia nem onde ficavam mas está
feliz da vida
e aí depois da próxima ganey fomos para
celebrar a si que acontece em são paulo
ganhou em primeiro lugar
outras premiações de lá já fui de
janeiro credencial para ir a mostratec
rio grande do sul ganha em primeiro
lugar e fui pra espanha e lá aqui
barcelona fomos ganhei também uma
premiação como melhor projeto
internacional participei da rio +20 e aí
eu pensei que já tinha acontecido tudo
na minha vida desse já estou realizada
achava que a conhecer belém já posso
dizer que já conheço uma partícula né do
nosso estado do nosso brasil e até mesmo
nunca imaginava atravessa fronteiras e
aí vem a oportunidade de participar do
quadro jovens e vetores do caldeirão do
huck
já regiane o título de jovens inventores
do caldeirão senhoras ian
rejane silva 20 anos de abaetetuba no
pará para o palco do caldeirão tá chique
mais em que ia falar antes de anunciar
que eu fico muito satisfeito em
conseguir provar através de jovens
inventores a capacidade transformadora
que a educação tem quando você analisa
você diz eca a sua vida água mas na
minha que mora em todo o pará
uma casa de madeira que estava vendo ali
palafita que acorda quatro emendas vai
pra escola
você podia abandonar a escola não o
colocou na teoria o time do programa
escola set e depois ver o teu discurso
tão claro tão eficiente tão convincente
tão transformador uma coisa que pode
fazer simples mas tem todo o fundamento
temor orgulho de você aqui e peço mais
uma salva de palmas
agora sim com a regiane silva de 20 anos
tinha vai ter tudo no pará é eu tenho
que agradecer
i
[Aplausos]
eu agradeço primeiramente a deus porque
ele tem sido tudo na minha vida e também
as pessoas que ele tem colocado na minha
vida pra me ajudar
primeiramente meus pais e depois o
professor que me deu essa oportunidade
não é fácil se envolver com pesquisa dá
trabalho mas o resultado maior quando a
gente vê aquelas pessoas com um sorriso
no rosto diz assim valeu a pena regiane
ea gente você está passando esse
trabalho sendo que o resultado está
sendo por nós e minha felicidade e o que
eu estou tendo hoje mão aqui o
reconhecimento que hoje eu vou investir
na minha pesquisa vou chegar onde eu
quero porque eu creio que quando a gente
quer alguma coisa
se a gente for lá atrás a gente pensa
que a gente consegue
e aí gente
quando eu ganhei esses 30 mil o que
aconteceu eu ia eu estava estudando para
prestar o com o vestibular não passei
que iria pulsão engenharia de pesca e aí
a minha maior vontade era pegar esses 30
mil pagar uma faculdade revista pra mim
pra mim com se prosseguir no meu estudo
mas aí quando eu olhei e vi o que a
minha família tinha passado comigo tudo
quanto ele tinham feito por mim
e nessa época que vocês estão vendo
quando chove a gente não sabia se estava
dentro ou fora de casa porque era muita
chuva e aí tinha vezes que era aparecia
sempre cobras porque a maré subia enfim
eram muito difícil quando chove a gente
tinha que esperar passar a chuva passar
para a gente voltar para a nossa rede
que aí a gente voltava a dormir
então o que eu fiz comprei o terreno e
aí eu fiz a casa dos meus pais não tirei
nada pra mim apenas peguei investir em
uma casa para eles e eu pensei assim se
eu cheguei até aqui com os meus esforços
se eu me esforçar um pouco mais eu vou
conseguir fazer a faculdade passar
aquilo
quero e cursar a faculdade que eu sonho
e aí deus enviou essa pessoa
a fernanda que foi me a jurada e
ofereceu uma bolsa de estudo para
escolher a faculdade que eu quisesse
expulsar que ela irá pagar para mim e
até hoje escolhi fazer a administração
porque foi uma área que eu me
identifiquei de vida tudo isso surgiu a
oportunidade de abrir uma empresa para
poder vendê-los matapis em alta escala
ea partir de o dsu tudo foi só a vitória
estou aqui para contar isso porque eu
acredito muito que quando a gente coloca
a deus acima de todas as coisas se a
gente quer isso a gente percebe que a
gente consegue
e todo mundo é capaz obrigado